I was just talking about two very
impressive women in politics now I'm
going to speak about a little
something of a less impressive woman in
politics that would of course be our
vice president Kamala Harris
who gave a a rousing oratory yesterday
on school buses
so here's the thing
right can you
can you love a yellow school bus right
just there's something about
the and and most of us many of us went
to school on the yellow school bus right
and it's part of it's part of our our
experience growing up
I say this without any malice in my
heart
specifically toward Kamala Harris or
I think any hyperbole
this might be the most vacuous human
being ever to walk the earth
if you ever
heard
emptier words
from an emptier suit of a politician I
politicians say meaningless things all
the time but this woman only ever says
meaningless things
uh Madam vice president what what do you
think you're going to be doing now how
is the administration going to Pivot
well it's really important to continue
to do the things and to do the things
now that we were doing that we've been
doing from the doing
okay Madam vice president you've got the
floor please tell us what's on your
heart please give us your vision of the
future who here likes a yellow school
bus
don't we all love yellow school buses
nobody cannot like a yellow school bus
so actually first of all fact check
no one who rides a yellow school bus
likes a yellow school bus because it's
school children who like who ride the
yellow school bus
and school children don't want to go to
school they want to stay home and play
so she's actually even in as much as
she's making any kind of claim
which is really tenuous here even that
really tenuous claim is is false even
that really thin just not that is false
and then of course the whole thing is
just so
silly and sad
because every single Kamala Harris
feature interview
is just an excruciating process of
watching her try to figure out
desperately how she can get anyone to
like her even a little bit what is
that's why what she never says anything
that that could ever be construed really
is controversial
or that it makes any real substantive
claims at all because the moment you
make a substantive claim you alienate
people who disagree with those claims so
she just generally says nothing and then
she does it in this really desperate
like her her muscles are stretched on
her face and she's always got that crazy
cackle
right don't we all love air hey who
doesn't love hair
right can you can I be president yet no
you can't
you can't it's really sad Joe Biden also
has no convictions whatsoever he's just
much more talented than she is that's
how he's remained in National politics
for 50 years not the brightest bulb in
the pack he doesn't believe a damn thing
whatever he did believe he sold that out
long ago but at least he's a little
better at the art of politics Kamala
Harris is not she's made her way in
politics
by other means we'll leave it at that to
be diplomatic you know to be gentleman
lay who says chivalry is dead but it's
it's it's a real warning people write in
a lot on the show and they say Michael I
want to be more involved in politics and
some people say I want to run for office
even or I really at least I want to get
involved with the campaign you know how
do I do it what should I do and
especially when young people write in
they'll say how do I get involved I'm 19
years old and I just always think
make sure
before you do it
you are doing it for the right reasons
the first thing you have to ask yourself
before you get involved with a political
campaign or before you run for office or
even before you go out and spread your
opinions in an article or a podcast or
TV or whatever is
why are you doing it
why what do you hope to achieve
in politics
and
when it comes to politicians like Joe
Biden and especially Kamala Harris
they just want to be in politics that's
it they just want to be in office
Joe Biden just wanted to he's just
wanted to be the president forever
Donald Harris just wants to be the
president
what do they want to do do they want to
get tough on crime or go soft on crime
they've held both positions they don't
care
do they want to
Institute a kind of moderate Centrist
policy or do they want to move far to
the left they don't care they've held
both points of view do they want to be
Hawks or doves do they want to be this
that you go down they don't they've held
every position on every single issue
they are not conviction politicians they
just want to be in office and so when
you don't believe anything
it it can you can last for a while you
can kind of last in the background for a
while but it it it makes it very very
difficult for you when the going gets
tough
because you you really are rudderless
you have nowhere to go and so now Joe
Biden and Kamala Harris would do
anything they don't care they wake up in
the morning they lick their finger they
figure out which way the wind is blowing
but they just they because they have no
beliefs and no vision for the country
they just they're just stumbling around
and you're seeing that reflected in
their poll numbers and what the American
people want is Clarity okay no one wants
a flatterer or a panderer in office okay
that flattery and pandering it's very
offensive
okay that's why it's why they don't
understand wait a second Rhonda Santos
has been tough on certain Hispanic
immigrants why do the Hispanic voters
like him because he's he talks straight
and he says this is what I believe and
here's why I believe what I believe and
here I'm going to give you an argument
for it I'm going to stand by the facts
and the facts are going to be true six
months from now when the Democrats are
trying to rewrite all of history and run
away I'm going to be standing by what I
believe and and people respect that P
the voters are a lot smarter than the
Democrats have given them credit for
people just want to be respected they
want a Clear Vision and they want some
courage right now the Democrats are
failing on all of those fronts now today
today was supposed to be a very special
day where I almost kill my friend and
colleague Jake crane we are pushing that
to tomorrow we're switching tomorrow
which is fake headline Friday to today
because listen we live in Biden's
America Up Is Down and left is right and
black is white and so everything's crazy
you've got to stay tuned I need your
help to figure out which the fake
headline is because the news cycle is so
so crazy four real headlines one fake
one the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it if you're not
a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
[Music]